individual self-fulfillment over the
duties of raising children she spoke at
a breakfast sponsored by the Mercatus
Center at George Mason University for
about an hour okay morning everybody
like to welcome you on behalf of the
Mercatus Center and George Mason
University to our ongoing distinguished
scholar breakfast series for those of
you who are perhaps unfamiliar with the
series we have put this together with
last several years the idea being that
there are numerous faculty throughout
the country in the world for that matter
whose interests and research into areas
of markets and market processes and
economics are somewhat different than
what we are perhaps used to talking
about here in the hill and washed in a
daily basis the mercatus center
obviously brides ourselves in our
ongoing examination of markets and how
markets work and lessons that we can
learn both good and bad from that
process and what we try to do in these
forms is highlight a topic an issue that
may be a little different from say
prescription drug price which may be a
good thing given the early morning hours
that we have here and today is no
exception to that I'm very pleased to
have festered Cheney robach Morris with
us a former colleague of ours at George
Mason who we have forgiven her for
fleeing to California but that is that
is that and I'm sure actually her return
in the heat of June is probably
reinforced that decision I'm sure for
those of you actually curious how many
in the audience here are parents all
right so we got a dividing line between
those who know and those who either
don't want to know or think they know
and are going to find out at some point
in time we pride ourselves in sort of
the Western political and economic
tradition of a liberal democracy and
limited government and freedom of choice
and all these nice expressions and we
and we pride ourselves in our first
child comes into the world until they're
two or three years old and then we
understand the late in totalitarian
tendencies that we perhaps have in our
system and there's nothing like looking
at a three year old who's of course
begging the question of why and why
why or thou shalt thou shalt not and you
find yourself we were into the old
Maxima your parents did have because I
said so it's a horribly life changing
circumstances I've had to go through it
now several times anyway today we're
going to have a topic about about this
sort of general concept economics is
really about the specialization of
self-interest it's really what economics
is it's maximization of that can be used
for good certainly but that
fundamentally is what its core is
obviously the family unit in the various
forms that it now takes is far more
significant to that concept in terms of
how society functions what happens when
this world of love and economics I
daresay collides but again those who are
parents know that the word collision
frequently occurs and that's we want to
talk about against a little off topic
but the lessons that come from that
whole dialogue still are applicable
still are very relative and employ
policy world professor Morris was gonna
talk for about half the time here the
rest of the session will be devoted to
questions by way a brief background she
has been teaching economics for about 15
years Yale University and then most
recently at George Mason particularly
with our colleague organization Center
for the Study of public choice she's
also a frequent writer believer Forbes
on issues of the workplace and child and
few other things so i'm very pleased
she's come back and I will turn this
over to her and we will explore the
discussion of love and economics
together thank you and I'm now at the
Hoover Institution California he forgot
to mention her gardeners but yes um
thank you very much for having me here
it's a delight to be back in Washington
DC and see a lot of my old friends and I
am especially pleased to speak to a
group of people who are astute on the
subject of the of the free market and to
talk about this subject of love and
economics when betty Friedan launched
the feminist movement with the feminine
mystique she called the frustrated
housewife the problem that has no name I
say that the modern industrialized world
now faces a new problem that has no name
and I call it the lazy fair family
each member of the laser fair family
pursues his or suit his or her own
self-interest and expects a tolerably
good outcome to emerge as if by an
invisible hand this approach to family
life contains numerous problems within
it and these problems undermine people's
attempts to build happy families people
are suffering I believe because they're
confused so in this talk I'm going to
try to answer three questions first of
all what is the laser fair family second
what do I mean when I say it doesn't
work as I say in the title of my book
book and finally what does the laser
fair family and its problems have to do
with the proper relationship between
work and family first what is the lace a
fair family the lazy fair family is one
in which each person pursues his or her
own self-interest members of these
families apply economic ideas to their
personal family lives now this
phenomenon of the lazy fair family is
not restricted to trained economists or
even to people of generally free market
persuasion by no means indeed many
members of what we might call the
lifestyle left usually no friends of
free markets are among the most
vociferous advocates of the use of
economic model what amounts to an
economic model in their private lives
freedom of choice among consenting
adults is the gospel for this kind of a
person and in America probably most
laser fair families have pretty weekly
defined political views they simply use
economic thinking in their lives not out
of ideological conviction but out of the
generalized individualism that's such a
prominent feature of the American
character now advocates of the free
market may be surprised to hear some
kind of criticism of laissez-faire from
a person like me and indeed being
sponsored by an outfit like Mark ADA's
now my argument is not with lazy fair in
general but with what I believe to be as
missin to the family the family is an
area of social life and which allows a
fair was never particularly intended to
apply also free market advocates might
dislike the terminology that I've chosen
here because an attack on the lazy fair
family might suggest an alternative like
the government-run
family that's the usual dichotomy that
we think of an economic reasoning we
have either a presumption of a minimally
regulated free market or a presumption
of any and all government intervention
interference and control that the
political sector might decide to justify
now I maintain that this is a false
dichotomy the alternative to the
laissez-faire family is not the
government-run family so let me assure
you all of that right away before you
all head for the exits the proper
contrast is not between public and
private or collective and individual
these dichotomies which are so familiar
to us and economic reasoning do not
serve us well in analyzing the family
rather we have to assume that the
primary responsibility for the conduct
of family life takes place in what we
would normally call the private sector
and the issue is how shall we in the
private sector in the privacy of our own
homes view ourselves and our behavior
regarding the family my premise here is
that a reflexive application of economic
ideas to family life has led us to take
an unreasonably self centered approach
to family life now in one sense the word
that's not surprising after all
economists focus almost myopically on
self-interest so it's that that we have
to find an alternative for the
alternative to the self centered
approach is the self giving approach to
family life self giving is consistent
with some of the deeper values held by
many free market advocates who respect
the market because it honors freedom and
the individuality of each individual
person my suggestion of placing
self-giving at the heart of the family
is certainly consistent with the dignity
of each individual far from denigrating
the individual self giving actually
elevates the worth of each person seeing
oneself as a gift proves to be a greater
act of self valuing than seeing oneself
as a set of desires in need of
satisfaction or as a set of opinions in
need of assertion here are some of the
primary miss applications of economic
reasoning to family life which I believe
have proven so destructive
the first and probably the most
prevalent idea is that marriage is
nothing more or less than a contract
among consenting adults a second problem
flows directly from this and that is
that the only limits on the types of
family structures are the choices made
by consenting adults the modern
insistence on no-fault divorce and
unlimited remarriages flows directly
from that idea so does the idea that
cohabitation can be a genuine substitute
for marriage the alternative to viewing
marriage as a contract is to view
marriage as a covenant not only between
the men and woman but also with God the
purpose of this covenant is the
sanctification and spiritual growth of
each member of the couple as well as the
building up of their community of mutual
love now obviously for many people in
our secular world the concept of a
covenant with God is incomprehensible so
I think that many of those people can
easily understand the idea of a
partnership between the spouses a
partnership based on mutual cooperation
for the purpose of building a community
of mutual love and so in my arguments
here today and in the book as well I try
as far as possible to appeal to this
vision of the purpose of married love a
vision that I believe is accessible to
large numbers of people even those who
do not consider themselves religious now
the alternative to allows a fair
approach to family structure is to see
that the family is a particular kind of
social institution and that as a social
institution it has needs and constraints
of its own the arguments in favor of
free market economics are based on
specific conditions that are peculiar to
the market in my book I offer more
extended arguments to show that the
conditions that favor freedom of choice
in the commercial realm are not
necessarily applicable to the family and
if you'd like to go into that we can do
that in the question and answer session
yet another misapplication of economic
ideas is to judge other family members
on the basis of how well they satisfy me
this attitude has a tendency to reduce
other people to the status of
commodities we ask ourselves am I
satisfied
this relationship without realizing that
a more brutally blunt version of the
same question is what's in it for me
it's the short step from that idea to
the idea that people can be disposed of
if I'm not happy with them a final
misapplication of economic thinking is
to view the family as a collection of
people who simply transfer transfer
resources among themselves in various
ways parents provide food shelter and
medical care for children but reducing
the parental role to the transfer of
resources invites the notion of
substitution people other than parents
can provide these same resources to the
children paid child care providers can
be an adequate substitute for maternal
care government programs can fill in for
services that parents fail to provide
now the alternative to viewing the
family as a collection of resources is
to view the family as a cluster of
relationships and a community of love
the primary function of the parents is
not to transfer resources to children
rather the most important role the
parents play is to build up
relationships with their children and
with each other parents transfer
resources to their children as a
byproduct of building up a loving
relationship with them seeing the
relationship as primary helps us to see
that not all programs that transfer
resources to the family or to some
members of the family will be genuinely
beneficial to the family as a whole some
government programs and indeed private
industry policies can displace parents
and actively interfere in the
relationship building that is really at
the heart of family life now that I've
explained what i mean by the
laissez-faire family and given an
overview of the alternative let me
explain why I believe it doesn't work I
believe that there is a new modern
definition of freedom that lies at the
heart of our problem here according to
this new definition of freedom a person
is free if he or she is completely
unencumbered
by human relationships all relationships
are chosen and contingent know
relationships are given and absolute a
woman is free only if she's not required
to be in a relationship with a child or
with a spouse reproductive freedom means
having an unlimited right to sexual
activity as well as an unlimited right
to a border contraceptive efreeti
doesn't want to have similarly persons
not free if he or she is required to get
married to remain married this
understanding of freedom generates the
right to divorce for any reason or for
no reason unconditional marital or
permit or parental relationships
constitute an unacceptable infringement
on the modern person's freedom finally
no self-respecting modern woman can
consider herself free if she's
financially dependent upon a husband or
on any other man this notion of freedom
is monetary independence has created
what I'd have to say an almost
hysterical demand that women must work
at all times during her life cycle
regardless of her family situation this
in turn places a very high priority on
substitute child care if a woman's
Liberty depends on her financial
independence then it follows that this
Liberty depends on the availability of
alternative care for children now any
resident of a modern industrialized
western country will recognize these
cultural currents that I'm talking about
now I want to argue that this social
sexual definition of freedom is in
conflict active conflict with older more
modest definitions of economic and
political freedom i define political
freedom broadly to mean the right to
participate in the governing process
economic freedom is the right to acquire
and dispose of property and however
desirable a person might consider this
new form of social freedom surely we'd
have to agree that it's not necessary to
having the political and economic
freedom that I've just mentioned more
importantly this modern understanding of
freedom is ultimately incompatible with
these older and more modest definitions
of freedom this is true
for two reasons the first reason is a
social and collective reason while the
other is a personal and individualized
reason a society that defines freedom as
the absence of unconditionally committed
human relationships cannot remain free
and individuals who define freedom in
this way are abandoning the very thing
that has the best chance of making them
happy in short I will show that the
notion of freedom as complete personal
independence is incoherent at the social
level and inhuman at the personal level
so first let me explain why I believe
that a free society relies on committed
family relationships a free society
requires people with a conscience the
vast majority of people must obey the
rules voluntarily not because they're
afraid of what the police might do to
them a free market in particular needs
people who can trust and be trustworthy
people who don't take advantage of every
possible opportunity to enrich
themselves at the expense of others the
terrorist attacks on September levites
showed us how much our freedoms depend
on people having a basic attachment to
the society a handful of people turned
our freedom against us as a result
everyone now accepts greater levels of
government scrutiny and control than we
would have ever thought otherwise have
been willing to but we do not develop
trust or trustworthiness or
self-restraint in a social vacuum now
most social scientists and philosophers
think about the conscience in terms of
arguments and justifications for various
moral rules and prohibitions we
academics tend to take a rather cerebral
view of this process of conscience
development but actually that whole
academic discussion about rational
self-interest and self-interest rightly
understood as we sometimes call it that
concerns the specific content of the
conscience we overlook the fact that
having a conscience in the first place
depends upon having a whole host of
prior conditions being in place a person
has to have the desire to do the right
thing they have to have a willingness to
learn
out right and wrong and the ability to
follow through and do what they know to
be right all of this is logically prior
to figuring out the specific content of
the conscience now the remarkable fact
is that this moral ground work is not
rational at all but it is relational we
develop this not only in the
precognitive period of our lives but in
fact in the pre verbal period of our
lives the groundwork for the development
of the conscience is laid in the first
18 months of an infant's life in the
process of being in a relationship with
his mother let me demonstrate this by
counter example let me look at one of
the most common patterns of life for a
child without parents children who are
abandoned by their families often end up
in orphanages and their experience
reveals to us some things about human
development that we might otherwise
overlooked children who are deprived of
human contact during infancy sometimes
fail to gain weight or to develop this
failure to thrive syndrome is well
documented some scientists now believe
that the presence of a nurturing figure
in the child's life actually stimulates
the growth hormones now all of the
bodily material needs of the child are
met in these orphanages the child is
kept warm and dry the child is fed
perhaps by having a bottle propped up
into the crib the child contracts no
identifiable illness and yet the child
fails to thrive and may in fact die the
widely accepted explanation is that the
children die from lack of human contact
more importantly these children without
families often have difficulty forming
attachments to other people even
children who are later adopted by loving
and competent families sometimes never
fully attached to them experts believe
that children who do not develop
attachments in the first 18 months of
life will have grave difficulty doing so
later on and if the parents do not
intervene by the time the child reaches
12 years of age the prospects for future
intervention are thought to be
diminished to the point of hopelessness
now the classic case of an attachment
disordered trial is a child who does not
care what anybody
of them the disapproval of significant
others is not a deterrent from bad
behavior because there is no significant
other nobody's significant enough to
matter to the child the child does
whatever they think they can get away
with no matter the cost to other people
they respond to physical punishments or
maybe loss of privileges but not to
disapproval they lie if they think it's
advantageous to lie they steal if they
can get away with it they may go through
the motions of offering affection but
people who live with them sense a kind
of phone eNOS they show no regret at
having hurt another person or they may
offer proof um tree apologies they may
find it fun to torture animals as they
grow into adolescence these children may
become sophisticated manipulators some
authors refer to them as trust bandits
because they're superficially charming
in their initial encounters with other
people they can charm people for short
periods of time only to betray the
person's trust by using them in the
meantime their parents and anyone else
who has long-term dealings with them
grows increasingly frustrated frightened
and angry over their child's behavior
which by this time may include lying
stealing violence and fire setting as
the parents try to seek help for their
child they may find that the child is
able to work the system they can charm
therapists social workers counselors and
later maybe even judges and parole
officers this child is unwilling to
consider others or even to inconvenience
himself for the sake of others who is
this child with this is Homo economicus
rational calculating economic man the
person who considers only his own good
who's willing to do anything he deems in
his self-interest to do all of his
actions are governed by self-interested
calculation costs and benefits he
doesn't self monitor so he can always
find some opportunity to break the rules
he breaks his promises if he deems it in
his interest to do so now plainly this
is not a person who's fit for social
life most people would just call this
character sociopath and not dignifying
with a scientific sounding latin
name this person cannot be turned loose
with the ordinary freedoms of movement
and choice that most members of her free
society take for granted and a society
cannot manage very many people like this
and still remain very free now the
desperate condition of this left alone
child shows us that we economist and
political theorists have been all along
counting on something more than mutual
interests of autonomous individuals to
hold society together we have taken this
something else for granted even though
it's been right under our noses all
along and this missing element is none
other than love how does love make the
difference between a sociopath and the
kind of person who can be trusted to
pursue their own self-interest without
causing too much trouble to other people
an infant experiences needs which they
cannot satisfy by themselves the baby
cries out for help help arrives and the
help does more than satisfy the trials
immediate bodily needs the assistance of
the other person allows the child to
learn to trust if the adult world
responds to the child's needs the child
learns that it's safe and beneficial to
trust children of normal loving parents
learn that all that anxiety they work
themselves up into is not really
necessary mom and dad are going to show
up and take care of them children
eventually learn to relax into the
loving care of adults who are in the
loving control of the situation and in
the process the infant comes to know the
human contact is the great good that
ensures his continued existence as a
byproduct of caring for the most basic
bodily needs the parents call out the
child's longing for human contact the
longing for human contact ultimately
develops into a longing for the deeper
attachments that we all use really call
love the ability to restrain oneself is
an integral part of being trustworthy
people need to restrain themselves from
taking advantage of opportunities for
immediate gains both the willingness to
trust and the ability to restrain
oneself flow in some sense from the
attachments that people have to each
other
a child will learn to suppress some of
his immediate desires for the sake of
the comfort of other people he learns
not to scream out for anything he wants
he learns to wait his turn he learns to
share his toys these are all primitive
forms of cooperative behavior and they
all of course require self-restraint
child development specialists have
traced out the course of moral
development in the following sort of
path first my parents will punish me if
I do X whatever the forbidden activity
is my parents will punish me next my
parents won't like it if I do X the next
step is my parents might not find out
but if they did find out they wouldn't
like it next I won't like it if I do X
and finally I'm not the kind of person
who even thinks about doing the
forbidden activity whatever it is now
for any of this progression of
internalized prohibition to take place
there must be a significant person in
the child life the other person is
significant precisely in the sense that
the child cares what the person will do
and what the person will think their
disapprobation becomes attacks a cost on
bad behavior now once again the
attachment disorder child provides us
with an instructive counter example
normal people care what other people
think of them attachment disorder people
are dangerous precisely because they
don't care what anybody thinks about
them that's why they seem to be out of
control they can't control themselves
and they don't readily accept correction
from other people losing the esteem of
significant others is an important
motivator for most people throughout
their lives most of us do not avoid
crime because of anything that the
police or criminal justice system is
going to do to us we avoid crime because
we're afraid of what our parents will
think it's only the attachment disorder
child who's literally running cost
benefit calculations on every
opportunity for getting away with
something normal people don't even begin
the calculations the cost benefit
program is overridden by the thought
what would your mother think what would
your father say before the calculations
even begin and in fact that's what the
mothers and the father's of the world
want their children to think don't even
think
bought it why because if you think about
it you'll figure out that some time
crime will pay so you don't want that
line of calculation or that line of
thought to even get started this is the
importance of the job done by a loving
family the family calls out from the
individual the capacity to have regard
for other people a free society requires
self restraining self-monitoring
self-governing adults but we're not born
as adults in spite of what some
romantics might think actual babies are
not noble savages there are just cute
savages who have the potential to be
civilized but it's not a foregone
conclusion that any particular child
will be civilized it's the unconditional
love of the month of the mother for her
child that creates this first most basic
attachment between the child and the
rest of the human race this attachment
provides the foundation for the
conscience and for reciprocity it's no
exaggeration to say that civilization
depends on a good first year this is why
the family though I the free society
needs the family this is the social
reason why defining freedom as the
absence of human relationships is
self-defeating and ultimately incoherent
now to satisfy the individualist in the
audience of which I know there are many
at a gathering like this I promised a
more personal and individual reason why
the modern view of the family and
freedom doesn't really work the pursuit
of happiness is incomplete without
unconditional love defining freedom as
the absence of personal antagonists is a
recipe for misery now every adult knows
that there's no magic formula or
guarantees for happiness in this world
but there are some strategies that we
can safely rule out as having no chance
of success I argue that defining
personal freedom and human relationships
as if they were unnecessary conflict
with each other is an approach that has
no chance of making people happy and
here's why I say so or such confidence
human beings are social creatures our
relationships with our family
and friends bring us the most lasting
satisfaction in our lives think about
September 11th the people trapped in the
upper floors of the World Trade Center
did not stoke up their computers and
take one last loving look at their
resumes or their stock portfolios most
of them got on the phone and called
families or loved ones to say one last
final goodbye to them and in the
aftermath of those experiences many of
us have come to realize how important
our families are in relationship to our
careers and our possessions we might
even say that the human body cries out
for community biologically genetically
no individual is going anywhere by
themselves we need one another for
reproduction it would be odd if this
primal need for each other did not
translate into some specifically social
realm of our lives now consider the two
organic natural purposes of sexual
activity obviously reproduction is one
of the natural purposes of sexual
activity humans have this in common with
other animals but the second organic
purpose of human sexual activity is to
create unity and love between the
spouses sex brings a man and woman
closer to each other and builds up their
connection and relationship with each
other so far as I know animals are
humans are the only animals that
copulate face-to-face and I think this
is not an incidental fact but actually a
central fact of building a social order
community building is at the heart of
both of these organic purposes of human
sexuality in loving one another and
sharing intimacy a man and a woman
create a community of love between them
in bringing forth a child they create a
new little community of love in their
own home now this little community of
love should be an inspiration to us all
but especially to those of us who
celebrate the spontaneous order
especially spontaneous orders of the
marketplace the concept of spontaneous
order an order arising without conscious
design has an occupied a central place
in economic thinking ever since Adam
Smith now of course that household is
into commercials establishment but look
at how the family creates cell
everything in the family arises
naturally from the attraction of a man
and woman to one another no central
planner needs to direct them to get
married and explain to them what to do
the primary motivations for the
household arise from the love of the
couple from each other and for the
children that result from their love
this little society is held together by
love now by contrast the modern
interpretation of human sexuality has
turned sex the ultimate community
building activity into a consumer good
the modern mind denies that sex is about
creating communities of life and love
sex about pleasure and enjoyment to be
exact my pleasure and my enjoyment the
inherent social nature our social aspect
of sexuality has been lost this is where
the usual dichotomy between public and
private doesn't work very well for us
sex is certainly not a public activity
either in the sense of performing it in
public or in the sense of being subject
to governmental control or oversight but
at the same time sex is not strictly a
private activity either every sexual act
has ramifications beyond the two people
who engage in it whether performed in
the context of marriage when performed
in the context of marriage sex has a
potential to build up the family's life
of life of community of and love through
both of its organic purposes when
performed outside the context of
marriage there's almost always some
third party who's affected by what's
going on moreover the sexual urge is one
of the few biological drives that have
the power to draw us out of our natural
self-centeredness now make no mistake
about it we are self-centered The
Economist's are correct to insist upon
this point in infancy our neediness
helps us to notice notice other people
and come to trust them as I've explained
as we grow older we become more
independent we have to interact with
other people but as economics teaches us
we could meet many of our material needs
through impersonal transactions with
strangers that's what the marketplace is
really all about and we could easily
create an entire lifestyle of having
only instrumental or commercial
pation ships with other people but our
desire for sex has the potential to
derive to draw us out of ourselves we
come to care about another person what
they think what they feel and what they
do our impulse our self-centered impulse
is to see that person in terms of what
they can do for us which in this case is
to gratify our sexual desire but an
adult person is not going to stand for
being used in that way the fact that I'm
attracted to a guy doesn't mean that he
has to become involved with me and so in
this way I can acquire a deeply felt
urgent need to find out what he's all
about who he is what makes him tick I'm
not entitled to sex with any particular
person I have to invest something of
myself in getting to know him in order
to win his interest in me this is the
essence of how sex is at its heart a
social activity a community building
activity and this is the proper
alternative it's not between private and
public but we need a third category
which is to say social which is outside
of either of those two categories the
way we normally think the natural
purposes of sexual activity our social
pursuing a sexual relationship
characterized by respected stability
forces us to consider the other person
as a person and not simply as a means to
self gratification the modern approach
to sexual activity is profoundly
anti-social we've transformed this
natural engine of community building and
sociability into a consumer good the
modern world celebrates sexual activity
as a source of pleasure separated from
either spousal unit e or procreation
much of our culture endorses our impulse
to see the other person simply as a
potential object of desire rather than
helping us to redirect it towards the
good of another person the culture
encourages us to have sex without either
commitment to a spouse or to a child the
spouse is no longer one's unique sexual
partner and if my sex partner is
replaceable then we can look at other
people as possible substitutes but
actually the uniqueness of our partner
is
one of the most profound ways that we
affirm one another my husband is not
moviestar handsome I am NOT fashion
model beautiful but inside the
relationship of love we don't need to be
we affirm one another as if we were the
most beautiful creatures on the earth
when we are disposable to one another
we're always looking for a better deal
without the commitment of lifelong love
we can always convince ourselves that
there's another guy who's better looking
more clever or more prosperous all we
have to do is look around and we'll
certainly see somebody who's superior to
our spouses in some dimension or other
it's only with the commitment to
lifelong love that we stop looking
around and start looking inside the
marriage we look at our spouses and see
many wonderful qualities that are not
immediately obvious we see the quarks
that make them interesting it keep is
fascinated with them over a lifetime in
short we see them as persons and not
simply as objects of gratification when
we're looking around for a better deal
in a spouse we often imagine that we
deserve somebody better than the person
we already have but once we keep our
eyes focused inside the marriage we have
to look at ourselves as well as our
spouses we can if we're lucky realize
that we are not necessarily the perfect
creatures that we'd like to think that
we are it's the moment of truth when we
realize just exactly who our spouses
have to live with it's an uncomfortable
moment to be sure but it's also a moment
of grace at a moment of opportunity for
real growth how we respond to these
moments are at the heart of the moral
drama of each human life we lose all of
these opportunities if we insist that
freedom from commitment is our highest
value sex without spousal unity is a dim
shadow of the full human potential of
sex inside marriage now the modern
notion of freedom is independence has
consequences for parental relationships
as well as for conjugal relationships a
woman is not considered truly free
unless she's financially independent of
a man in practice this means the she
must work and placed her child with paid
daycare providers
but this mother is not really
independent this is a myth she's
actually very dependent upon her
employer and on her child care provider
without the employer she certainly would
not be financially independent since her
child's welfare is important to her her
own well-being is profoundly dependent
on the childcare provider on the quality
and competence of that child care
provider this modern social arrangement
of paid employment and paid childcare
has not eliminated the primal dependence
of motherhood she has simply transferred
her dependency from a husband to the
market relationships of employment and
childcare these commercial
establishments have no particular reason
to be committed to her or to her child
the modern insistence that mothers be
financially independent replaces a human
personal relationship with a commercial
impersonal relationship this is quite
simply inhuman this is why I say that
the new definition of freedom as
personal independence is incoherent for
the society and inhuman for the
individual a society that defines
freedom is the absence of binding
personal relationships will undermine
its most basic freedoms within a
generation or two an individual who
defines freedom as the ability to exit
any and all personal relationships will
sooner or later find himself with
nothing but in personal relationships
mediated by either the market or by the
government now what are the implications
of this way of thinking for public
policy now there are numerous
implications actually now some of these
implications concern how we view our own
contributions to the family and the
workforce other implications are
actually public policy things now the
most important personal implication of
this analysis is that people need to see
one another as persons and not as
objects or as instruments towards some
other end now that's simple enough to
say in the abstract but it's far more
difficult and practice to treat people
with this kind of regard here are a
couple of specific implications
we should stop looking at our marriages
in terms of what they can do for us when
we do this we imagine that we're taking
good care of ourselves that we're
protecting ourselves from being used and
abused I don't agree with this I believe
that this is an attitude of suspicion we
can easily come to view our marriages as
carefully orchestrated exchanges of
duties and promises I'll do something
for you if you do something for me this
suspicious posture comes from a
fundamentally fearful place in our
psyches we're afraid our husbands will
leave us we're afraid they'll use us
we're afraid we will not get our
emotional needs met the alternative to
fear is love instead of organizing our
lives around debating our fears we can
organize our lives around growing in
self giving love this actually requires
a far greater degree of self-confidence
than succumbing to our fears it's a real
act of courage to commit ourselves to
self giving knowing that we will
sometimes be disappointed in our spouses
it's a real act of self confidence to
know that we will survive those
inevitable disappointments seeing our
spouses as persons and not as objects is
the first step to greater intimacy the
next step is to see that love not youth
is the proper response to another person
and particularly to our spouses it's
always a serious wrong to use another
person how much more wrong is it to use
our spouses love is the proper posture
of one person to another another
implication of this change in posture is
a change in women's attitude toward
working surely the most important single
demographic change of the 20th century
was the increasing labor force
attachment of married women this is a
trend which of course most people
celebrate with the argument that women
are entitled to all the same sources of
power and status that are available to
men now the outward appeal here is to
women's pride but the inner appeal is to
her fears and her fears of relationship
we're afraid that we'll have to take
care of ourselves and our children all
by ourselves without the help of
in fear of abandonment fear of poverty
fear of the relationship failing in a
way we can't salvage these are the
secret fears the real sources of many
women's attachment to the labor force
modern woman has come to think of her
ability to compete in the workforce the
central hurt to her vision of herself as
valuable incompetent ones paycheck is
tangible proof of one's intelligence
creativity and value many women go so
far as to claim that they should be paid
for motherhood since this would
demonstrate the society values their
contributions there's the less
flattering interpretation of all these
attitudes I'm working because my
self-esteem depends on it I'm working
not so much to feed my family as to feed
my ego the alternative is to see my
talents as gifts to be used for service
the question is what ends shall my gifts
serve I can place my talents my
intellect in my education at the service
of the family rather than at the service
of my vanity this puts a whole different
spin on the question of whether I have
to work and therefore have to put my
children in daycare I do not necessarily
have to work outside the home therefore
I do not necessarily have to have child
paid childcare provider I can adjust my
work to meet my family's needs and this
leads us to public policy in my opinion
government should not be paying mothers
to put their children into commercial
care this is an impact of the current US
tax policy that gives tax credit for
paid childcare government should not be
giving benefits to unmarried mothers
instead government should facilitate
speedy adoptions of children into
two-parent families further it would be
helpful if the government gave generous
tax benefits to married couples with
children in the United States this has
been done through get granting a small
tax deduction for each child in the
family however this amount has steadily
eroded in the world in the years since
world war two and could easily be
increased implicit in this vision
implicit in my recommendations is a
vision that should guide public policy
concerning the family let me make that
guiding principle explicit I mentioned
it at the outset and I'll renew it now
the primary function of the family is to
build relationships not to transfer
resources transferring resources from
outside the family should only be done
in ways that build up the family for
instance one of the insights behind
welfare reform the United States was the
fact that the structure the programs
essentially replaced husbands with
welfare checks husbands and fathers
became replaced with money from the
government this undermining of the
family had vast ramifications for every
aspect of people's lives another set of
policy implications is has to do with
how we view equality between men and
women the modern American feminist
movement has spent most of its energies
trying to make women's career paths as
similar to men's as possible equality
and justice have been defined in terms
of equality of outcomes pretty much at
every point in the career path I believe
that this effort is fundamentally
misguided instead I think we should be
trying to make everyone's career path
more flexible so that people can move in
and out of the labor force that are ways
in ways that are more compatible with
family responsibilities as those family
responsibilities change over time we do
not need more highly structured labor
markets with more elaborate sets of
benefits mandated by government we need
more flexibility in benefits hours work
and in the creation and retention of job
skills this kind of approach would be
more consistent with the ever-changing
reality of combining worth and work and
family for men and women alike we might
add the modern redefinition of freedom
has created havoc and families and in
the wider society the modern world is
defined freedom to mean being
unencumbered by human relationships I've
tried to show that this understanding of
freedom is incoherent for society and
inhuman for individuals it's no surprise
that an era of this magnitude would
generate destructive public policy but
correcting the public policies really
only scratches the surfaces of the
changes that we need to make far more
fundamental are the changes that we need
to make in our attitudes no government
can make us change our ways of thinking
and
nor would we even want them to try we
need to do this part of the work
ourselves we need to move away from a
distorted individualism into a more
constructive socially engaged
individualism we need to see the dignity
of each individual is something that
makes him worthy of love not an object
for use or a source of fear we need to
see the importance of the individual now
strictly as a consumer or as a voter but
is the only agent that can truly change
a culture only in the family can we
begin to change the climate of mutual
suspicion into a climate of mutual love
from this we can create a society that
combines the best aspects of the modern
world without succumbing to its vices
starting at home we can create a
civilization of love thank you very much
for the record I used to do nasty things
to frogs and oh I do i do aim for cats
we're going across the street in front
of me quite we flee I might add which is
probably reason why I've chosen a career
in politics again we have a few minutes
left for questions there any I can leave
with one but you
what you said except for your conclusion
where you were you seem to suggest that
we as policymakers should think of how
this world impact on the on the family
and strengthening the family but isn't
it of a more help you up but wouldn't it
be better for all individuals and
whatever kind of social arrangements
they live their lives if we as
policymakers simply stopped making so
much policy and focused on the limited
constitutional roles of the federal
government which is National Defense
coin the money and run the post office
and given the great job the federal
government has been doing and running
the post office I certainly don't want
them trying to make make my family well
I'll tell you what I'll make you deal if
you can get the federal government to
dilute itself to just those topics I'll
go home and never say another word on
the subject okay I mean but the fact of
the matter that the world in which we
live is a world in which government
makes a wide variety of policies that
have all kinds of implications and I
don't think we're thinking through the
implications properly so I think
something has to be I agree with your
minimal government vision but I think
something has to be said to guide policy
in in the in the meantime so to speak
given that
it's what up close to fifty percent of
an average family's income goes to state
local and federal federal taxes isn't
that that's one thing yes obvious it's
an obvious thing to do and in part of
the issue with that is that whenever
somebody says well women have to work in
order to support their families the
truth of the matter is the second error
in each family is working to support the
government you know and we don't often
look at it that way but the median
income just for the record is the last
time i looked at the statistics for the
median income family the biggest single
bill they pay is the tax bill and it's
about forty percent of the median family
median income families budget and so and
so therefore you know obviously the tax
code has not kept pace with preserving
any kind of family values of what might
have been in the immediate post World
War two period it was on the order of
fifteen percent that the median family
income was paying so it's this is
obviously a huge part but it's it's
hidden from public discourse in many
ways so I I think the point to make is
that the secondary earner in the
household is working to pay the
government and not to put food on the
table you know that's and I think people
lose sight of that particularly when
they're talking about mandating new
benefits and and things of that sort
which ultimately have to be paid for
want to move to a foreign policy for a
minute if you're talking about in
Western society certainly notions of
commitment and love etc especially
marital relationships I think makes
sense to a lot of us but not all
societies operate that way we have
situations where certainly you know the
rights so does because we would define
them of women or our wives would be far
different than what we have here the
basis for the relationship either being
arranged etc is very different and in
many cases we look at the world of
economics and Marcus as sort of
liberating to what we might be what we
might look raps down upon as a
relationship where there was never loved
to begin with there's not really any to
be
in that situation isn't isn't sort of
the notion of you have inherent rights
you have self-interest that can be
liberating or and doesn't that affect
how we sort of treat other countries in
our foreign aid policies or are we
saying that we go down that road that
there are outcomes that we may not
desire from social I look nothing that I
have said in any way takes away from the
basic point that all individuals have
basic fundamental economic and political
rights and human rights it takes nothing
away from that whatsoever you know so
you know that on that score there's
there's nothing to touch there is
nothing to discuss you know now as far
as other kinds of marriage practices and
and and so forth in other parts of the
world I would be very reluctant to say
that we should you know go explain to
the Moslems why polygamy is a bad idea
something like that although I think you
can make a coherent case as to why
polygamy is a bad idea I think you can
make that case but but I I think that's
a long way from what we should be doing
as far as foreign policy is concerned so
I'm not sure where you're headed with
this Lawson but I think it's a mistake
to to start with basic human rights you
know and say you have a right not to be
tortured you have a right to a fair
trial and to put those rights in the
same category with reproductive freedom
and to say country isn't free if they
don't have abortion on demand the way we
have that kind of foreign policy i think
is really quite destructive and you know
there's a treaty that's being considers
i think you all know that has to do with
that that has do the commits it claims
to be having to do with the rights of
women but in point of fact what it's
doing is to enshrine a certain set of
rights that are very new even in Western
societies and say that you're not really
free unless you have these things well
that's a mistake in a society where
people are being tortured in a society
where there's no habeas corpus in a
society where there's no property rights
I think it's kind of foolish you know to
go down the path of saying well they
they all need all the rights that we
have in this particular area you know
that does which we ourselves didn't have
50 years ago I mean that just that seems
to me to be seriously misplaced
priorities in addition to all the other
reasons why I think you could make an
argument why some of those countries
have very good reason
for having rules against abortion that
are different from ours and so forth and
so on I mean I just don't think that
should be made a fundamental issue in
the way that some activists would want
it to be I'm just kind of interested in
how this kind of fits in economics
partly because you know we all start
with see the Robinson Crusoe who's an
adult on an island or we start with two
people trade and you know like you say
to get to the point where you can
recognize that somebody has something of
value you want to do something of value
not steal it case takes a while and then
just a whole you know you said in the
book how how much world would be
different if result with kept his
children is Valley Hospital or maybe of
Adam Smith would have been married you
wouldn't seven it's by the benevolence
of the parents for the butcher and baker
that we know our grid and so I just
wondered do you think you have something
here that can inform economics to change
the way it's taught to kind of like
melons kind of Imperial subject you want
to take over everything that red we do
out here if it doesn't seem that
economics has a very good way to
describe the family elma happens in the
family I mean supposing self-interest
but as a parent I don't deal with my
sons in a way that I've ever read an
economics textbook so you you use costs
and benefits with them that's for sure
right yeah we all do that as parents we
do costs and benefits and try to get
them to to to it to respond to that we
try to figure out what will get them to
respond so we're economist in that sense
but we know that our ultimate job is to
make is to make that whole process
irrelevant we can't be around them
hovering over them all the time with
carrots and sticks they have to
internalize that that's our job you know
is to is to be able to turn them loose
like that now do I have something new to
say to you can amex yes I think I do
this is my answer to Gary Becker you
know for those of you who know that line
of thought this is my answer to Gary
Becker that that a purely
self-interested way of viewing the
family misses something important and it
misses some important things because not
all
objects of desire are the same and that
has been the way that economics has been
an imperial subject we're being a little
bit academic here but bear with us the
way act the way economics has been an
imperial subject has been to say well we
know how people respond to things they
want so let's take all objects of desire
anything that people might want and
treat it using the economic or apparatus
and one way to view what I'm saying is
that not all objects of desire are the
same they have unique properties that
matter you know and and the gary becker
move has always been to say well those
differences don't matter well i think
you can make a coherent case that they
do matter you know that there are some
issues that we're what it really does
matter and the personal attachment i
think is the most profound one there
really isn't a substitute for your
particular spouse or your particular
mother you know no matter how crazy your
mother was no matter how bad your child
but you know there really isn't a
substitute and i'll say that as an
adoptive parent okay i am in a sense a
substitute mother and it would have been
better for my son if his birth mom could
have taken care of him that would have
been better for him but she couldn't and
so I I take over but the fact is that
reality for him can never be undone you
know there isn't some kind of substitute
arrangement that can make it that he
didn't have to be in an orphanage for
two years you know there's nothing
that's going to take that away and so
there are limits to the way we use
economic analysis and I precisely
because of the unique is some of the
goods
take your subtitle perkin and
I ran didn't have kids at her Smith was
a bachelor a lot of people are feeling
about it is reform Social Security
system I'm spiking touchdown on the
floors and stuff in your book which is
that an hour Cuba system going we need
people to work pay taxes their parent
generation and raise productive children
so that when they're adults they can pay
for themselves but we're living off of
everybody else's children not around so
there's little imbalance there what you
think of we designed the system so that
instead of people getting benefits based
solely on how much they contribute to
the system financially financial they
are a percentage of the children's
teacher earns you can arrange it so that
instead of people instead of people
getting on children's salaries and if
you're worried about raising children
who go off it all makers because that
would give you incentive to raise
children newer productive um I think
it'd be simpler I think the Cato
Institute plan would be simpler to just
privatize the thing you know I'm not
sure I'm not sure this is practical and
I haven't thought through what you know
what you're saying although I understand
what you're obviously what you're trying
to say the issue you bring up about the
homemaker I do want to say something
about that because I think that among
the critiques of the modern world I
suppose you'd say that the in crittenden
critique that mothers are not properly
valued because of Social Security I
think that's an area where there is room
for reasonable reform to make it
possible for women who are homemakers to
have some kind of not I don't want to
call contribution to have some kind of
benefit or to have have it arranged by
the spousal you know to rearrange how
the spousal contributions are done so
that it again again you're building up
the family unit rather
than breaking it apart into its
individual constituents you know I think
there is room for meaningful meaningful
reform in that area and I'm just gonna
let it go with that and not try to
specify what I exactly think it would be
yeah actually passed our time Jenny's
not gonna be fleeing yet so by all means
Dave I do want to officially conclude
this that those of you need to go may
make sure you grab a book on the way and
thank you Jennie for being here and
thank you all for being with us as a
quick reminder the second part of our
financial regulation course which could
not have come at a better time is this
afternoon at twelve o'clock just down
the hall and actually don't see you
there I'm sure you will hear from us
very soon about the next few months of
Catholic on campus so again on behalf of
Arcadis and George Mason thank you to
Jenny and thank you all for being here
thank you Jennifer robach Morris is
author of love and economics why the
laissez-faire family doesn't work it's
published by Spence online it spends
publishing com and now live coverage of
a briefing on Homeland Security
financing this is being hosted by equity
international at the podium right now is
the president of that group William boy
this is just getting any Webster in
charge of the operation of booz allen's
information analysis centers for the
defense technical information center
over the past ten years mr. Vincent led
the formulation of these islands
counterterrorism business involving
weapons of mass destruction this team is
involved in counterterrorism efforts
throughout the Department of Defense the
Department of Justice the intelligence
community the Federal Emergency
Management Agency and several federal
state and local government response
agencies projects managed includes such
activities as the nut